i can't lose a lover but i cannot lose a
lover and a friend
[Music]
because i am trans i wanted to train my
speaking voice to be something a little
bit different because my voice used to
sound like this i wanted to
have a voice that i was more comfortable
with
i feel like my range of voice is me
accepting myself at all angles
[Music]
[Music]
my name is nat puff i am a
singer-songwriter i also go by the stage
name left at
this is the range that i talk in and
occasionally sing in but when i sing i
also utilize my low range i have this
song called six feet for example that
utilizes both ranges the verses are like
oftentimes i scare my reflection
and then the chorus is like i know that
you don't know me but i know just who
you are
[Music]
i'm the only trans woman that i know of
that uses both ranges in songwriting can
i hear that back i'm going to be
harmonizing over it
and even if it's more commonly
stereotyped as men having that lower
range i'm not going to let that bring me
down because i know who i am
[Music]
if i succumb to the stereotype then
nobody wins
it took me about two years to
train my voice to go into both ranges in
the way that it has because it's not as
simple as just like talking in your
lower range and then talking in your
falsetto range because it sounds like
this and it sounds very airy and it
sounds very
weird you literally have to sort of
learn how to re-support your voice in
this range and that took a while
there's admittedly some parts of me that
still get a little bit dysphoric about
my voice like damn i had to go through
all this training and most other women
don't have to do that but i just
accepted and moved on and i feel like my
music is better for that
[Applause]
[Music]
i've had people come up to me saying
you've made me feel more comfortable
with my lower range even though you talk
in your higher range
people feel represented which makes me
feel happy that people can find comfort
in their own voice because having such a
strange relationship with my own voice
being that for somebody else is very
very special to me
[Music]
[Applause]
i feel like as an artist and as a person
and as a trans person as every part of
me is just embracing myself
[Music]
[Music]